at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking by 4 Sigma Dec I reached out to
these Finnish entrepreneurs after a very
talented Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which blew my mind and
the best way possible
it is mushroom coffee what on earth is
this well it includes chaga mushroom
very powerful antioxidant considered a
superfood I was introduced to chaga by
Laird Hamilton the king of big wave
surfing of all things and it includes
another mushroom that is considered a no
tropic a smart drug and this is lion's
mane in the entire packet you just add
it to hot water tastes like coffee
there is only 40 milligrams of caffeine
so less than half what you would find in
a cup of coffee so you I do not get any
jitters I do not get any acid reflux or
any type of stomach burn and it put me
on fire for an entire day and I only had
half of the packets so this stuff is
really amazing people are always asking
me what I use for cognitive enhancement
right now this is the answer so it is
legal it will not give you visuals
that's something else and you can try it
right now by going to four sigma tech
comm forward slash tim that is for sig
Matic SI GM 80 I see for sig Matic
dot-com forward slash Tim and use the
code Tim to get 20% off your first order
if you are in the experimental mindset I
do not think you'll be disappointed for
sig Matic comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on the show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
all front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
little boys and girls wombats and
squirrels this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct to a world-class performers
tease out the habits routines favorite
books etc that you can use in your own
life and I'm speaking in hushed tones
because I'm in the airport and I don't
like to yell and scream like a lunatic
when in the airport lest I get a boot on
my head so the guest Mike Birbiglia I've
wanted to interview Mike for years you
can find him on twitter at bur biggs bir
b IG s he is one of the best known and
busiest working comedians in the world
both behind and in front of the camera
his stand-up blends a lot of elements
different elements theatre films
storytelling and comedy this is of
interest to me because he's been very
deliberate and studying different crafts
and tying them together and this is
reflected in his string of successes
which include sold-out tours as a solar
theatre act he just did a hundred cities
not too long ago near Times bestselling
books off-broadway shows feature film TV
and much more in the last few years his
work has started to appear on this
American Life which is an incredible
show and a podcast for those interested
where he be in a meaningful
collaboration with the host and producer
Ira Glass who I'd love to have on the
podcast at some point currently Mike is
the creator writer and star of the new
film don't think twice which is
hilarious heart-rending just a wonderful
watch I saw an early preview copy and it
blew me away so I highly recommend it I
don't say that lightly it's a great
movie if you've struggled with notions
of feeling like a failure hoping for
success achieving some degree of success
and then getting more or less than you
bargained for it's it's
incredible journey so I do recommend you
check that out and how the hell does he
pull all this stuff off he seems to be
juggling million projects I am to find
out we dig into it so without further
ado please enjoy Mike Birbiglia Mike
welcome to the show
thanks Tim it's a very exciting and
timely for me to be here because because
I'm digging into all of your stuff and
immersing myself and it is affecting my
life in real-time so speaking with you
is almost a virtual reality experience
well I think this is mutual feeling
since I've been a consumer and fan of
your comedy for so long and I've started
thinking after Elon Musk hints that we
could be logically speaking players in
some sophisticated future entities video
game that this might all be a virtual
reality I'll be a very sophisticated one
but if I wanted to bring us back to the
earth at least as we understand it for a
second I paint a number of mutual
friends of ours
Brian Koppelman of course famous
screenwriter all-around good guy Chris
Sacca both of whom have been on the
podcast before because they've spent
some time with you and I wanted to ask a
number of things that they brought up so
the first was from Koppelman and I asked
very specifically does he have any
obsessions that you know of outside of
comedy and one word back pizza so can
you elaborate on this please it's such
an embarrassing obsession is it simple
you know it's it's it's bread and cheese
and sauce I mean it's a hearing you say
that makes me realize how simple of a
human being I am I have a joke from my
first album to drink Mike which is I
love pizza so much I would marry it but
it would just be an elaborate ploy to
eat her whole family at the reception
but it's uh so seven so stupid with IE I
love pizza I think it's just you know
it's the simplicity of it it's from my
childhood
it's there's no deeper meaning other
than my
by the time my mom raised me I that's
that's Freudian saying that because I
was raised by my mother and father but
my my mother was around more often she
really kind of gave up on parenting and
ordered pizza a lot yeah you know like
she didn't want to cook that much so
she'd just be like let's just order
pizza she just got very used to it and
and now I figure well in my adulthood I
might as well be a connoisseur and have
good pizza so what now qualifies for you
is good pizza if you could have one type
of pizza delivered to you and I'm sure
there are many options but is are you a
deep dish are you a New York style thin
crust what are we talking yeah yeah I
think there's two kinds of pizza that I
like most one is New York New York thin
crust : and places like Arturo's and
Luke Holly Ludo and then I have this odd
you know from my childhood just in
Massachusetts there's a ton of Greek
pizza just there's all these sort of
greasy Greek pizzerias that I grew up on
and and so I have a fondness for that
like so if I'm driving dogs like all
through New England so if I'm driving to
my parents house and you know I'll stop
in Connecticut I like either side right
like a pizza read on the side of the
road and like a suburb of Connecticut
and just get pizza the the old and the
other one the other pit stop there's New
Haven has extraordinary Pizza - really
never would have guessed in a million
years it knows there's something that
characterizes Greek pizza other than the
fact that it's made by Greeks is it the
same ingredients or do they do anything
particularly no no it's same ingredients
it's just it's just sort of a it's a
medium-sized crust pizza but I mean
there's a million theories on pizza most
people say it's based on you know the
water I mean there's book there's books
and books written about pizza but you
know that's people say it's its water
base what makes it good which is why--
for whatever reason New York Pizza is
better in my opinion than in most places
and actually the reason compliment is
also
bring that up I think is that I would
have these readings for my film don't
think twice at my house to workshop the
film script the way that I would work I
workshop my stand-up and I would always
I would have over people like Brian
Koppelman Michael Weber you know like
the Lord came to one of nicole hollow
Center and I would always have the best
pizza like I have Luke ollie
or I have Lutz oh and I would say at the
beginning of the reading the script
might be bad but at the end we're all
gonna eat it's dealing with the grade
schoolers great ineffective I always
urge people I was urge like
screenwriters or anyone who needs
feedback on their work to just invite
people to something where you give them
something to give them food give them
ice cream give them pizza and and try
and solicit their feedback because
feedback I think is the most valuable
thing you're gonna have for your right
so let's let's talk about well two
things since they came up the the movie
first of all I was very excited to get a
sneak peek I suppose early access or
Vimeo and I'm only a half-hour in but
I've loved it I watched it actually with
a friend and also a former podcast guest
Cal fuss Minh who wrote great yeah what
I learned column or a large portion of
four decades for Esquire and we both
after watching the portion we watched
because I had to jump on the phone to do
this interview number one he said well
you should skip ahead to see the end so
that you can discuss it with Mike and
and I said no no no I want to actually I
want to watch the rest of the movie the
entire movie tonight so I was very
pleased and relieved that the movie is
really really good and it made me I'm
gonna die Gress her because that's my
style but so many moons ago I actually
took one and it was the only improv
class at this place called boba no
casting in San Francisco I remember it
brought that memories and it made me
want to go take improv classes as well
as go see good improv yeah but so that's
so the the don't think twice I would
highly recommend people check out and
sokka loves it as well and it gets
better by the way
gets better I mean I'm not even I'm not
even through and act one
yeah I'm it's nice that you haven't seen
the whole thing because I can dance
around things and so that the listeners
don't aren't spoiled on things and but
but yeah it gets better but what one of
the comments that came up from Cal and I
concurred was that the writing was
really good so I want to talk about the
workshopping
what is the format like could you
explain how you workshop the material
and then in what at what stage do you
workshop it I conceived this idea my
first film was called sleepwalk with me
and it some people want to see it it's
on Netflix it's easy to find and and
after I made it I I went back to
improvising at UCB theater after years
of kind of taking time off from improv
I'd studied it in college etc and the
reason I went back to it is because UCB
ups Upright Citizens Brigade Theatre in
New York and Los Angeles actually and
the reason I went back to it is because
I realized that so many of the
principles it's probably the similar you
know the principles that that you see at
the beginning of the movie that you
probably studied in your class say yes
it's all about the group don't think you
know just do and all those principles
are really what got me through directing
a film which was the hardest thing by
far I've ever been in my entire life and
I after I directed it I was like how the
hell did I even live through that like
how did I even stay alive and I realized
that it was all these things in improv
that had taught me that and so I veered
back into doing improv and one that my
wife was brilliant came to one of my
improv shows and she made this
observation and I thought it was
wonderful which is she goes it's because
I think it was on that on that given
night it was like it's a guest
improvisers sit in with me this show
called micro biggley's dream and any
given week it'll be like a V Brian from
SNL or Ellie Kemper from Kimmy Schmidt
or like you know Zack Woods from Silicon
Valley and and she said my wife said
it's amazing watching this art form with
these people because it's all about the
group and how everyone's equal but in
real life
that person's a TV star that person's a
movie starting that person shares a
one-bedroom in Bushwick with five dudes
who live on air mattresses and I thought
man that's not just a great observation
it's a whole movie I mean that is a
whole movie to me and I could just see
the movie and I started just writing out
just this really kind of throw up what I
call what I'd call a throw up pass of
them of the movie script I would go to
coffee shops in the morning for three my
minimums three hours I stick myself in a
coffee shop with no internet and no
email no anything and then if it's going
well I go up to five hours and if it's
not going well I I just end at three
hours but and then I was a sorry to
start interrupt what do you have us do
the time that you've generally used for
that age I knew 7:00 a.m. I try to do I
try to write before my inhibitions take
hold of me right so I almost tried I
always say right because I'm an actor as
well I always say right in a trance and
act in a trance like it's almost like
you you don't even want to think
consciously about what you're putting on
the page for fear of oh you wrote this
down in your book you eat you write them
as emails to people right in and I think
that's such a brilliant it is that
that's in your book right yeah no it is
and just for people who don't have that
context I or I might have talked about
in an interview perhaps where I said
that I basically threw out the first few
drafts of four or five chapters of the
4-hour workweek because it was either
too pompous or too slapstick and then I
decided to literally go into an email
compose window and write the first
chapter as if it were just a letter to a
close friend after me having had two
drinks that was basically that's so
that's so brilliant and a lot of times
what I do is I'll write in my journal
as though it'll never be seen by anyone
ever and then more often than not the
things I put in my secret journal are
the things that that I publish and when
you sit down at the coffee shop 7:00
a.m. or just beforehand couple of things
do you have a particular type of coffee
or bed
fridge and then do you use word do you
use I do AI do a cappuccino and I do
magic movie magic screenwriter is the
program I use or I write in a notebook
by hand I try I try to write as much in
my hand in an in a looking nice notebook
at all you know that has some meaning to
me sometimes I'll have my friends like
once I was on last summer I was on tour
for the movie trainwreck and with Dave
Attell and Amy Schumer NASA Bear and it
was my birthday and Dave Attell got me a
journal like it was really sweet he's
you know you just like gave me a little
gift for my birthday bought an uber in
Seattle on tour gave me a nice journal
that's really nice one of my one of my
favorite stand-up comics never had any
interaction with a really awesome
amazing yeah one at one of the greats
and and I asked him if he would sign it
on the just in the back somewhere and so
he I have like a Dave Attell notebook
and so it's a signature series well I
think of it as like it's blessed you
know like sometimes when people ask me
like sometimes people ask me to sign
their notebook and I'll write like I
bless these jokes and then I'll write my
friends like um you know Andrew Andrew
das who's a musician who's in the band
fund he came to see my Broadway show
think of their jokes and he actually
brought me a journal like as a gift and
and I asked him if he would sign it and
so he wrote this like nice note and I
think there's something about the
personal element and the personal
relationship with notebooks that I think
can can be helpful to the writing a
couple of really I guess perhaps mundane
questions but I'm curious Don the last
movie magic screenwriter why do you use
that instead of say a final cut or
something like that
it's so stupid I mean I'm I'm a real
walk with screenwriting and like I
listen to the script notes podcast with
Craig Mazin and John August and those
guys just they despise final cut they
just despise it and or I'm sorry final
draft yeah you know what I always mix
those up that was I just incepted you
with the wrong information sorry yes
final draft but um and but anyway a few
years ago I stumbled across movie magic
and I like it and there's no there's no
good reason necessarily but so I write
and actually this is a real quirk that I
rare
we admit to anyone never mind in public
to get to finish the script I found that
I kept putting it off and putting it off
and putting it off and I was analyzing
my habits and I was like I'm putting
that I'm putting off writing this script
but I'm not putting off you know having
lunch with Brian Koppelman or you know
having it's my brother or whatever and
so I I thought well I'm always on time
and I always show up to things so why
don't I do that for myself and so what I
did was I put a note a handwritten note
next to my bed that said Mike and it has
three exclamation points Mike you have a
meeting at Cafe peddler that's where I
was writing at 7:00 a.m. with your mind
which is so stupid that it's so
embarrassing to admit but it worked but
if it works it works there's like yeah
if it works worse I was like well I have
a meeting it doesn't matter that it's
with myself but it's a meeting and I
have to be on time I love that I love it
the the human mind is such an odd
amalgamation of sensical and nonsensical
behaviors I just love it when you brain
vomit I vomited that script out in a few
weeks
is it scenes do you start with just
stream of consciousness lines you want
to include and yes it goes from stream
of consciousness I'd like to see a scene
of this I'd like to see see in this I'd
like to hear this piece of dialogue I
wrote down like a head of a corkboard my
walls like it's it's silly when you see
my office it's just like a wall of cork
board and one of the three by fives I
put up I put up all of these mind
writing slogans which you can look up
you know things like quotes from you
know there's a Azra pound quote that I
have in my wall that literally three
words I think it's one of the best
quotes for her writing only emotion in
doors and I always try to keep that in
mind when I'm writing because I think
that that's there's just a really
crucial idea you know what you said mind
writing quotes yeah that's that's um
mind writing quotes it's it's there's
they're just these kind of like you
you can do googles for like mind writing
quotes and it's like quotes from writers
collected over time by famous writers
and you can you know they're written up
and you know there's like lot like you
look around and there's like lions from
Hemingway and there's rot lines from
George Orwell and Jack Kerouac and and
it was funny because it was something
that Ellen the Baker who's a producer in
this American Life actually gave me as a
tip when I was writing my book sleepwalk
with me and other painfully true stories
she said she said I had when I wrote my
book she said I had all these mind
writing slogans on the wall and I and I
used it and I it's real I I find it to
be really really helpful so only
emotions and doers was that the quote
only emotion endures emotion what does
that mean to you well what it means is a
lot of times writer as a writer you get
hung up on you get hung up on cultural
references you know a lot of times like
okay if you see a comedian a lot of
times the way that I lose interest in
comedians for example or sitcoms or
movies or whatever is that it gets gets
hung like they get hung up on like a
cultural reference a joke about a
cultural reference that literally will
be gone in in four years or five years
like what you know there's a reference
to Twitter in my movie and and don't
think twice and I was very cautious to
think through the implications of in 10
years when twitch Twitter no longer
exists or is or becomes the myspace of
the future will that reference make
sense to the viewer and advance the
story and and because you know that I
always have to think in those terms like
there's a part of sleepwalk with me the
movie where my character is figuring out
how to drive to one of his gigs and and
he uses Google Maps and it's like a very
key visual and I had to think like okay
what's gonna be the mapping system of
the future and then like will people be
able to grasp what this mapping system
is in relation to the story in other
words like if you get too hung up on
sort of making jokes or in your serve
cultural jokes about you know things
that might go away then that whole five
minutes of the movie is sort of dead in
a way well it's it's I mean it's at risk
ephemera right I mean if when you have
that topical hook yeah yeah and so and
so my with this movie I was really about
like what is this about it's about
friends and so when it's it's about a
group of friends coping with what it's
like to be in their 30s and confront the
idea that they might not be successful
the way they thought they were gonna be
successful in life and what does that
mean what does that mean for their lives
what does it mean for their friendships
and so it was it was about like whenever
it would veer into something that was
like a cultural reference I would be
like no no no let's pull it back to it's
about friends and so that's what I mean
by mine writing slogans and then I would
have also on the wall like things that
felt like principles for the movie like
I would I wrote like when my wife or
maybe the observation about how
everyone's equal on stage but offstage
they're completely unequal I wrote on
the wall this thing I made up which is
art is socialism but life is capitalism
and that was like a guy for the film
which is like this how is that how can
that be a conflict between his friends
you should you should add your own quote
to the mind writing course question well
you know Bernie supporter but it doesn't
have to be I get their point so the net
at what point then do you invite your
friends over and ply them with pizza
what would form like how rough is it
when you give it to them two months and
it was yeah I started writing two years
ago in end of April and then like June
the June 10th I had people over and so
it was a two months and draft and I had
people over and I said you know I
preface it I say it's an 8-man it might
not be good and thanks for coming and it
was ended I had like 10 or 12 of those
at my house they ended up being some of
the most fun part of the process
entirely because he's you know it
because there's
there's really no stakes to showing your
friends your work I mean it feels like
their stakes I was very nervous and and
you know but but there it's just there's
something communal about that there's
something fun about it and do you do a
table read do you have people take roles
or do they just all react silence and
then give you feedback how does a work
no note so i reaiiy have them read it
aloud and like I would have my assistant
at the time Greg would read this great
screen directions and and a bunch I
would assign parts and I would highlight
the scripts for people and then we'd
read it aloud and then we need pizza we
just kind of talked about uh what what
it made us feel like you know my my the
director of my one-person shows is this
guy named Seth Parrish she's really
brilliant theater director and he um he
always does this thing dramaturgical II
which is good word he will listen to I
will pitch him what I'm working on what
my idea is or a piece of writing I even
did it this week because I was asked to
write a piece for a storytelling about
in Nantucket Film Festival and I read it
to him over the phone and so he and then
he says back to me well what I get from
that is this and it's like this nuts a
non-judgmental way of interfacing with a
collaborator so so in other words you
know I I give him he reads this script
and then he says you know what would I
get from it is it's a group of friends
and you know one of the men's up being
more successful than the other and then
they're all trying to figure out what
they're doing with their lives and so if
that's
if he says that back to me and I think
to myself well no it's more it's more
than that it's actually about this this
this and this and he says well that's
not what I got from it it's actually
helpful to the process because it's I
think one of the most important things
about writing is that that you that
people are getting what you're intending
like I listened to an interview with Ron
Howard where he was talking about how he
he shows his movie two tons of test
audiences and it's not so that they can
tell him what the vision for the movie
should be in the rough cut form but it's
to find out whether his vision is
landing with people and if it's not
landing and if they're not he's not then
he's not conveying it correctly he goes
back and rework so a lot so that's how
that's how I like to think of the
screenplay process and what I like to do
is I I like to work out like what I'm
doing essentially in my living room in
you know in my little shabby apartment
in Brooklyn is basically what they're
doing on like the hundred million dollar
level in Hollywood with tons more money
and fancier offices and and to bathe its
quote-unquote development in Hollywood
they develop these screenplays for years
and years and years and it's all these
executives giving notes but I don't want
executives to give notes to me I want
writers to give notes and I want actors
to give notes I want collaborators who
actually do do the things that I like
and and and who I aspire to be like I
bring I like invite people over who are
way better writers that may like I I
have no business like getting notes from
Phil Lord you know who's the director of
you know 21 Jump Street and you know the
lego movie like he's just leo but
brilliant brilliant Mike but who cares
I'm just gonna ask him to come if he
doesn't want to come that's fine too and
and do you generally say go through a
five-minute scene in its entirety and
then people do post-mortem and give
their their thoughts or will they read a
line and then say you know what like
that my character wouldn't say that
that's weird it sounds stilted like how
do you how do you actually
facilitate we read it start to finish so
we read it as though it's a table like a
table read for first it comer or a movie
and and then at the end we just kind of
adjourn and you know some fiery
discussions start you know a lot of
people give their thoughts and they
really conflict with other people's
thoughts and those people fight with
each other and I listen to that it's
really helpful so you don't swear on
stage generally as I understand it
although Sokka said one or two funny
exceptions perhaps in a more recent and
then the recent show think up for jokes
I actually dissect why I don't curse
gratuitously on stage and and why in
some ways in the think of her jokes show
I departed from that a little bit which
I can explain yeah please please explain
because for instance I've been I I'm an
avid consumer of stand-up love it and
have have I've heard for instance dirty
Jim Gaffigan but yeah he is he's largely
sanitized but he can often pull it off
right and said what is your logic behind
your approach my logic was it started
off in kind of an embarrassing way which
is to say that my parents were very
upset that I was going to pursue comedy
they my mom my dad's a doctor my mom's a
nurse
those are professions were people help
other people and are ashamed of their
artistic children and and so but my mom
was so upset when I was moving to New
York and and she said just don't become
one of those dirty comedians and I said
okay and she said you don't have to use
those words to be funny
for example Oprah is very funny and I
was like mom I'm not sure you understand
my goal I'm not trying to be the queen
of daytime but you know it stick it
stuck with me because you know you want
to make your parents happy you know you
want to pursue your goals but you're
also you know these people gave you
everything and so you have to heed
you should heed that to some extent and
so I've tried not to curse for a lot of
years um but I do
I do feel conflicted about that sometime
because a lot of comedians I admire most
did curse on stage Lenny Bruce Richard
Pryor and then some of them who famously
don't curse are secretly criminals and
yeah and so and so I I'm somewhere in
between that I will say that I don't
curse gratuitously more often as as word
choice then it is to sanitize it for
people who object for you know Christian
reasons about words like look I have no
problem I curse a lot quite a bit in my
life but I but when you're a writer I
think that word choice is important I
think word variety is important so if
you sit I don't know if you personally
podcast but I do I do occasionally but I
try not to say that if you say the
f-word you know 75 times in an hour
that's poor word choice like you're
gonna being create it's lazy it's lazy
it's like using the adjective
interesting as a modifier for yes yes as
a matter of fact they're just brilliant
film that calls out at that point at the
festival it's called captain fantastic
and it's coming out I think maybe in
September with Viggo Mortensen it is
I've heard so a friend of mine saw a
screener and said it was fantastic I
haven't either fall but it's a it's a
father who raises his family in sort of
the woods like off the grid so to speak
in Washington's day and he he won't let
the kids say the word interesting
because it doesn't mean anything and I
it's actually it called it it made me
reconsider that as a word choice and try
to panitch it from my vocabulary but but
anyway the point is is that the f-word
is not I don't think the F word is is
effective as a monologue if unless
you're using it to to to the right
effect to the kiddos see the great
effect for those who are interested in
delving into the etymology and various
uses of the word [ __ ] which is in fact
very flexible there is a book called
English as a second [ __ ] language
that is a fantastic short read I think
it has a
I might be making this up and Stephen
King don't sue me Stephen on the front
or some huge name who do you run jokes
by um I run them by primarily audiences
is uh I go out and I bomb with jokes and
I said see what lives I see you know and
and then also my brother Joe my brother
Joe took me to introduce me to comedy
when I was a kid he I was he was senior
in high school I was in eighth or ninth
grade and I was helping him write these
satire issues of the newspaper and then
so that was for my introduction into
comedy and then he took me to see
Stephen Wright live and that changed my
life that was when I was in high school
and and it just changed the way I
thought about everything it was like an
epiphany moment of like oh I want to do
that that's what I can do and I started
writing in my notebook and I wrote all
these kind of Stephen Wright ripoff
jokes and then really and there's wafer
our baking who has time for that exact
and yeah yeah I went to a when I went to
a drive-in movie in a cab movie cost me
ninety five dollars they're just great I
mean they're just endlessly great if
people are interesting that type of joke
another great joke writer that vein is
Mitch Hedberg Who am I yep so I'm in but
uh but anyway sup once I saw Stephen
really oh this is over I'm doing this
and then when I was in college I entered
a stand-up comedy contest and and I
wanted so it got me a chance to perform
at the DC improv and then I got a job
sort of working the door at the DC
Improv and and and but the point is is
that my brother Joe and and I always
would kick around jokes like ever since
you know I was like 19 years old and now
he he's worked for me or he's worked
with me we run our production company
for the last ten years together I like
poached him from being an ad copywriter
because he had gone sort of the route
and my parents had wanted me to go and I
veered into comedy and then I sort of
brought him along when I was able to
financially do that pulled him to the
dark side I pulled him to the dark side
and he's yeah he's an extraordinary
writer and uh and so I run everything
by him but but the big thing is also
like I run you know I run sup by Ira
Glass when we're working on something
for this American Life
I run stuff by Seth bearish when we're
working on something for one of my
one-person shows and then my wife quite
a bit and then audiences I mean the
audiences are the the big determiner of
what is worth saying a lot of times if
you're in front of
and when I say audiences I don't mean it
doesn't have to be 2,000 people I mean
you know 10 people at the Comedy Cellar
on 2:00 in the morning I can understand
whether a bit is going to work you know
for five years I love watching comedians
work on material and I've seen a number
of them with notepads who are friends of
mine working on material they'll
apologize after the fact I'm like no are
you kidding me like this is what I want
to see I can always see the finished
product on HBO or wherever it ends up
coming out this is the in process stuff
that I want to see me too I love it and
so let me dig into some of the details
and see if there's anything to discuss
so the process of eliciting feedback
when you pass something by someone let's
just say it's it's comedy and you're
talking to Ira Glass or someone like
that are there any particular questions
that you ask and the reason I bring that
up is that when I have my friends who
are writers proofread my writing let's
say for a book I asked them first to
highlight anything that is confusing
like whether that were unclear like I
whether they love or hate something is
secondary to clarity right as long as
it's clear they can hate it but I want
them to understand what I'm saying and
then yeah it kind of goes on from there
that's simple that's similar to the Ron
Howard idea is what is what I'm creating
being conveyed the way that I meant for
it to be conveyed right and in it so in
your case you know IRA is a brilliant
man but not a comedian as far as I can
tell
although he has this moment very funny
certainly
with someone like IRA or anyone else how
do you is there a particular way that
you elicit feedback to make it as
helpful as possible I usually I usually
do it I'll tell people bits and jokes
over the phone
partly because they can sort of
peacefully peacefully give feedback in a
way that doesn't feel so judgmental when
you're face to face with somebody it can
be hard to to say a joke to them and
have them feel the pressure of oh I
should laugh or I should politely
respond on the phone it's pretty easy to
just kind of like skim through stuff and
I can hear I can hear when people are
interested by what I'm seeing said you
know quentin tarantino often III ever
i've read this
quentin tarantino will call people
endlessly and pitch the movies that he's
working on and he says he doesn't even
have to hear the laughter he can he can
hear in their silence what their
interest level is it's like the silenced
whisper there's some truth to that like
when you pitch people if you pitched up
to people all the time after a while you
kind of get the sense of like are they
hooked or are they not if they're not
hooked you're you should consider
another direction yeah yeah definitely
Tarantino is a fascinating case I'm
hoping to have him on the podcast
sometime in the next six to twelve
months which I think could happen uh why
do you think this is a very broad
question why did you make it so to speak
in business where very few people do
you've you've reached a level of success
across several different art forms but
let's just look at comedy in the various
iterations of that what were the
decisions you made or chance encounters
or mentors or whatever it might be that
contributed to you making it at least
that being the perception certainly when
I was 19 I had a bladder tumor and
was i high it was ended up being they
caught it early it was a malignant tumor
and so for the next every three months
for the next like five years I would
have to go for a cystoscopy where they
would look inside my bladder and see if
the cancer had returned and it didn't I
was very very lucky you know I'm you
know it's like almost twenty years later
and I go for cystoscopy like every now
I've really two years or so but that at
this exact same time that I had this
kind of life-threatening ailment happen
I started to do comedy I and I entered a
contest and I wanted I got this job at
the DC improv and I would watch every
comedian who would come through the DC
improv and I would watch you know in the
variety actually was really helpful it's
like I I saw Larry the Cable Guy before
he was a stadium act I saw you know Dave
Chappelle before he was Chappelle's Show
and George Lopez and Margaret Cho and
Kathleen Madigan Brian Regan Jake
Johansson Jim Gaffigan all these people
and I watch all of them and I would try
to bug them with questions and so I was
I had this kind of education in watching
a ton of comedy and going to open mics
and trying comedy at the exact same time
where I had this realization from cancer
that that life is short like in a tin
can and you know and it can end anytime
and it's like and and it's in some ways
the best thing that ever happened to me
was was that perspective because I
became an absolute workaholic trying to
get good fast like I wanted to become a
really great stand-up comedian really
fast and and so I feel like that that's
the thing that there's this comedian
Tommy John again who who started in the
Midwest and I remember he opened for me
one time when when he was in college and
now he's you know he's been on Letterman
a lot of times and he's got a great
career but when he opened for me like
when he was in college he like I had
done stand-up like once or twice and he
quoted this back
to me years later and said because you
gave me this piece of advice when I
liked the moment I started and it's
weights what made me sort of help help
me create what I've created as a career
which is if you want to perform five
minutes of good comedy write what you
think is three hours of great comedy and
because that's the ratio that it's gonna
be you're gonna you're gonna write about
three hours of what you think is great
and that about five minutes of that's
worth worth showing it audience that's a
that's a good quote and I remember
reading at some point I don't recall who
it was I want to say Neil Gaiman but
that's just because I have a secret
infatuation not so she can effectuate
that Neil Gaiman so this is something
helpful that I want to attribute to him
somehow which was a writer talking about
process and discussing the frustration
of say writing 9 or 10 pages and only
having one or two paragraphs at the end
be worthwhile and feel yeah and feeling
like the first nine pages were a waste
of time but then emphasizing no in fact
you needed those first nine pages so
that you could produce the two
paragraphs that are abused not only yeah
not only that I mean that's a brilliant
way of looking at it not only that
everything that you do in your life I've
realized over the years is leading to
where you are so in other words like the
fact that when I was in college I worked
at the door of the improv and brought
food to people's tables and then I was a
waiter at the tombs when I was in
college and then I was a you know I was
a temp in New York City at a
pharmaceutical company all of that
actually led to the life experience that
would be able to put something on the
page that feels real there's a I went to
a little talk at the Nantucket Film Fest
this morning with Oliver Stone and the
thing that I wrote down in my notebook
from it I take away was he when he was
like 20 years old he wrote I think a
novel
and it got rejected like all over New
York City like every publisher for like
two years they tried to get published
for two years and then he joined the
army and when he got out of the army
he because of the GI Bill was able to go
to film school and he made films and
what he talked about is that it was the
army that taught him to become
self-reliant in a way that allowed him
to understand how to make films which is
a completely he goes it the army is what
took me out of my head and made me
understand that it's not about being
just cerebral it's about being a
combination of cerebral and self-reliant
and being able to survive you know in
forest or whatever it is and and that's
sort of what went into this you know
epic film career that Oliver Stone has
had and and I think that that's that's
worth considering in this discussion so
given that which I agree with and how
old are you now Mike if you don't mind
me asking I just turned 38 this week
well happy birthday and if you are going
to give advice or could give advice to
your 20 year old self 25 or 30 so you
can pick if you could just you could
place us what you were doing where you
were what advice would you give to
yourself if any I would say write
everything down because it's all very
fleeting keep I would say keep a journal
which I have but I would be I would have
been more meticulous and then I would
say don't don't bow to the gatekeepers
at at the head of in my case
showbusiness but at the gate of any of
any business or any endeavor don't bow
to the gatekeepers because I think in
essence there are no gatekeepers I think
that you are the gatekeeper like that
has a vaguely Ghostbusters ring to it
also
Tsar lis true now in history when you
look at completely our
in in film and television and the
Internet I mean there's this there's
this amazing quote I think it's at the
end of hearts of darkness which is the
documentary about the making of
Apocalypse Now we where I think it's in
the end credits or it's one of the final
things Francis Ford Coppola pretty sure
in the 70s said that the the best movies
in the future because of the way that
technology is moving the best movies are
going to be made by like a kid I
remember it just from memory but like
roughly like a kid in Ohio who picks up
a camera and and starts shooting
something like that that's where
technology technology is gonna be
democratized and is and has been now in
a way that's unprecedented for film
certainly oh well you know I mean across
the board I mean you have kids who are
programming and piecing together
autonomous cars in their garages I mean
it yes it's really unbelievable although
as the technology or despite the
technological changes much like the
quote on your wall emotions and doers
the core components of good storytelling
I don't think are going to change all
that much no no and as a matter of fact
I would say the same thing for my sort
of 20 year old self is like is like
don't what don't don't waste your time
on marketing just try to get better yes
great advice I remember a blogger very
early on I think it was Robert Scoble
actually said to me good content is the
best SEO so kind of the equivalent of
writing online which is everybody's
trying to optimize for search engine
results it's like just put out good
content people will link to it yes and
that is how you get found it's it's it's
not a bet and also it's not about being
good it's about being great because what
I find the older I get is like a lot of
people are good
definitely it's like a lot of people are
smart and a lot of people are clever but
not a lot of people give you their soul
when they perform
true yes very very true so when when you
think of the word successful who's the
first person who comes to mind and why
I'm gonna I'll say a political and
non-political answer because I people
dislike this person that I it kind of
goes one in the air out the other Barack
Obama Obama to me is is very inspiring
he he came from nothing
he came you know and he didn't he became
president he's the president interstates
he doesn't have to because I feel like
lost on culture a lot of times he
doesn't have to be like he he doesn't
have to be the president he could be
like in extremely wealthy and he saying
look he could be on Wall Street he could
be a corporate lawyer he could be
anything that he could be in Silicon
Valley he could do anything that would
make one a person billions of dollars
and he chose to the insert working
service as a country that being said and
and I met him I met him at the 75th
anniversary USO last month which was
really cool but then I met him two years
ago when my wife was pregnant and Matt
and I we asked him we our whole thing
was whenever we meet someone who we know
doesn't care about meeting us we always
try it my wife and I always try and come
up with like a trick question
that throws them off and like they kind
of have to answer or think about it like
I I give this advice of people it's like
if you ever see Jimmy Fallon on the
street don't be like I love the Tonight
Show
just be like what do you think a Kiwi
you know do you mean like won't be able
to not be like I love Kiwi you know like
just half the people out of they didn't
think they were gonna talk about and
then next thing you know you're talking
to Jimmy Fallon about Kiwi and then
you'll have that for your life but so
what I it so so my thing our thing with
Obama
was let's tell him because my wife is
pride 4 months pregnant but we hadn't
told anybody yet as why don't we tell
him that you're pregnant and so when we
get to the front I go mr. president is
my wife Jan she's newly pregnant but
don't tell anyone
and any and he couldn't help the
President of the United States couldn't
help could be like Oh mother first alone
and and my wife says yes she goes do you
have any parenting and advice and he
goes oh well get some sleep and we're
like ha ha ha ha cuz he's the president
you know does he you know it's like
wasn't that funny comedic Lee but he's
like your boss times a million and then
he goes but he got better because he
goes well no actually I got something
because when you bring him home because
he goes when you bring him home the Pooh
president said Pooh and the moment he
said Pooh I thought this is the greatest
day of my life I could die right now and
I'd be fine he goes when you're bringing
home the Pooh doesn't smell it doesn't
smell like adult poop a dope poop smells
bad and then he looked at me for
affirmation over that mr. president
adult who does indeed smell terrible and
you for inviting me to the food 7 2015
and so and he goes and when you bring
them home he goes babies crave structure
they're eating and they're sleeping and
and he goes and if it doesn't you know
if in the breastfeeding doesn't always
work out right away and be a little bit
wonky don't freak out and if it doesn't
work out with the sleeping right away
don't freak out and any pause and he
thought about it and he goes that's
actually some pretty good advice
compliment his own advice but I'm
telling you the best thing you do is
you've got to give people questions they
don't what you're doing right now you
you got to be good people questions
they're not expecting and then and then
my my non-political answer people hate
Obama I get it whatever you're
Republican I don't care you know like
it's that's your issue but would be Bob
Dylan would be sort of the I I think Bob
Dylan is the great artists of our
time because unlike the Rolling Stones
or you know the Beatles obviously broke
up but some of them died but um yeah but
he he continues to grow and learn and
produce and to change and so I think
that for that is a time out of mind is a
top five album Bob Dylan album of all
time
and he made it you know what went in his
sixties you know it's like it's
unbelievable and they made in he made
freewheelin Bob Dylan when he's like 21
years old it's unbelievable that is yeah
when you've been doing it for three or
four decades to date you're do you've
definitely passed the once you're lucky
twice you're good stage yes the next
question I feel like has to be a de left
field for this to function after that
incredible Obama story so let me try a
question that I've been dying to ask
someone but I I feel like you might be
game for this but what are your rules
for good sex oh wow that is fascinating
the standard thing that captain
fantastic has this piece of advice in it
which is that is smart where the father
says so the son when you make love to a
woman be gentle and and I think he says
be gentle and listen and I think that's
wise and that's good advice I think well
I think you should have sex
assuming that it you're with your wife
or girlfriend wants this the more than
you think you should it's kind of like
pizza like it's never a bad idea
so maybe a myth I mean you could even
even add that to the list of incentives
for your friends when they're
proofreading I guess I mean and the
script might not be good but at the end
we're all gonna have sex that's the
qualification for the next routing
series that
get so many people in the door yeah
I choked on my first album which is
pizzas like sex when it's good it's good
when it's bad it gets on your shirt yeah
that's honestly the dumbest joke but I
still enjoy saying it is there a book
that you've given her books as
frequently as gifts I give people the
DVD I give a book sometimes but I more
often I give a DVD of stop making sense
not familiar with it it is the David
Byrne concert film with the Talking
Heads that Jonathan Demi directed I
think in the early 80s and it's just a
really innovative strange concert film
that's very much worth watching and and
taking in in a creative sense because
it's so unorthodox I mean it's called
stop making sense in it and musically it
pays off I think and I think visually it
pays off because it's very abstract so
that's the one thing I get the other
thing is just I give this book called
the problem people ask me about my
sleepwalking all the time because I have
obviously a very serious sleep disorder
where it almost killed me so I give this
book called the promise of sleep and it
was written by dr. William seed the man
who is the father of sleep medicine in
in this that you know decade or even
century and it makes a cameo in my movie
sleepwalk with me as himself but it's a
wonderful book and people often say to
me because of my sleep disorder what
should I do I have insomnia blah blah
blah I always say we'll get first of all
get this book and second of all the
basic takeaway for starters is you know
an hour or two before bed turn off your
phone turn off your computer and and and
and I forget what the third one is but
but but but yeah that's the biggest
thing is like think of don't think of
sleep as something that you don't crash
into but that you ease into like that
you that you're parking the car as
opposed to crashing the car
that's a good point yeah like that like
that analogy uh any other favorites
movies or documentaries
I love terms of endearment in broadcast
news or 2chainz L Brooks films that I
can just watch over and over and over
again and that and those are really the
the you know I'm a don't think twice my
makes sleep okay man when I make
hopefully the next eight or nine movies
I strive for to make movies like those
where you're laughing and and you're
crying it's me that's what that's what
all of it is for its to experience the
range of emotions within an hour and a
half or two hours if you is on that
point if you could combine three
comedians alive or dead into one super
comedian yeah who would you pick okay
so it would go something like this it
would go Mitch Hedberg I'm writing this
down on a pad Mitch Hedberg Doug
Stanhope Maria Bamford so Mitch Hedberg
I think is the greatest joke writer of
our time
I think Doug Stanhope is the most honest
comedian of our time and I think Maria
Bamford is the most vocally and
physically versatile unbelievable yeah
yeah I mean I I just think what she does
is uncanny I mean she drops into these
voices that are just like these these
completely vivid pitch perfect
impressions of people in her life and
it's it's it's uncanny and so I would
say those three that's a great question
by the way I've never gotten that
question well I'm gonna have to dig in
so I know Hedberg I know Maria Bamford I
haven't explored Doug Stanhope is there
any particular no there's one called no
refunds that's on next it is I mean
because all of his stuff is meant to
make people leave all the names of his
albums are things that imply that you
you can't get your money back so does
does that mean that he does what as I
understand it I mean I've listened to
and watched a fair amount of his stuff
but billboard
so it seems that bill burr will
deliberately lose the audience's because
it's no longer a challenge to simply
make them laugh he wants to be able to
reel them back in is that effectively
what Doug does it's yeah it's precisely
that I mean seeing Doug Stanhope live is
it's it's bill burr actually to the
extreme I mean to the point where I I
can't
it's like watching it's a magic trick I
mean it's like watching Andy Kaufman
doing his bit where he does like his
like Locke character speaking the
gibberish to the audience and like
bombing and people not realizing it's a
character and then going into you know a
perfect
Elva a pitch-perfect Elvis impersonation
having it say you know and people go
crazy it's it's it's this thing where
you can't believe that he lands the show
after how terrible he's made it and it's
it's fascinating and bill bird's ascent
yeah bill burr is incredible too I mean
though in the I mean bill burr maybe be
very close to that list as well yeah
Maria is I've listened to a lot of her
comedy and I being I suppose although I
alternatively love and hate this
description in the self-help business
mmm-hmm
which I try sort of not to think about
much but the I get asked about the
secret a lot and manifesting things
which is not really a focus of mine at
all what Maria has this hilarious bit
that I always mention I'm like you
should listen to Maria Bamford like she
talks about the secret there's this bit
where she she's talking about being down
and out and her sister is very
successful sort of corporate super
efficient and Maria has her over at one
point and Maria has put together a
vision board which is like a board and
there's a microwave on the board and her
sister goes a microwave really you want
a [ __ ] microwave that's depressing
I'll buy you a microwave and the Maria
is like BAM manifest oh my god so genius
what what purchase comes to mind could
be recent but whatever that has
positively impacted your life ideally
not like a Maserati but something that's
thing on the less expensive side oh it's
this is so this sounds so stupid and
like current and speaking of things not
enduring who knows what this will even
be but my eye I find the Fitbit was
helpful for me because it tracks my
sleep and so it tells me this thing
about my sleep which is you how much you
were walking the night before no it's
true it's true I mean it tells me it not
only tell I don't know if you know about
this it Donnelly tells you um you know
how you you know what how long you slept
but it tells you the quality of sleep
during you know in other words like it
tells you you know you slept technically
for eight hours but you you know you
were awake for an hour of that so it's
actually quite helpful I like it and so
you use it primarily for your sleep then
hey for my sleep yeah yeah I mean that I
like the steps thing I like trying to
get to 10,000 steps a day that's helpful
but for the sleep I mean cuz you got to
remember like I've slept over at
hospitals
you know countless times for sleep
studies because I have REM behavior
disorder and it's like $3,000 per visit
to any I was you know some of its
insurance but some of it I have to pay
and it I mean this thing basically does
a sleep study and it costs a hundred
bucks what what's what type of nighttime
rituals do you have mean you mentioned
easing in instead of crashing into the
wall yeah do you have any particular
kind of wind down or evening rituals I
try to do there there's a actually a
good podcast called not to be mistaken
with sleepwalk with me there's a good
podcast called sleep with me could go a
lot of directions okay yes and it's this
guy named he calls himself scooter and
he sounds trustworthy and he and he he
has like this really uncanny skill of
talking in circles and slow and a
circling back to the first topic and
then the next topic and then another
thing and then a digression and then
next thing you know you're asleep I mean
it's it's pretty fascinating what he
does that's the true that yeah so that
that's where that's weird looking into
and then and then I try to write in my
journal and then honestly the biggest
thing is getting off of social media
it's you know getting getting off of
Twitter and Facebook I think you know in
relationship to what we were talking
about earlier of like I was saying the
thing about Oliver Stone that he he
joined the army and be can't that's how
he became self-reliant and how
ultimately like everything in your life
that you do leads to who you are and
what you're able to accomplish I think
that social media is weirdly the
exception to that I think that social
media is like this weird kind of looking
in the mirror all the time thing that is
it's it's not helpful for for being
productive or or learning I don't I I
mean I I I don't know if that's true but
that that's been my feeling lately I
think the the dose makes the poison
certainly I mean I think there's a point
where you're like oh this title is
helping my headache and then oh my
stomach lining just fell out of my ass
no I mean that that hasn't actually
literally happened to me but there's
there's definitely a point where you
know things in excess become their
opposite what is the on the flipside and
the first kind of 60 to 120 minutes of
your day look like I mean are there any
particular rituals that you have in the
morning like momento every day injecting
your wife with insulin over and over
again like a lot of times if I'm not
focused I will kind of wander and and
you know it's until I've coffee
forget about up a heavy coffee drinker
and and if I'm on a prop basically if
I'm on a project if I'm shooting a movie
I have a complete and exact plan for the
neck
day and if I'm writing a movie like I
said I've looked and put notes next to
my bed you Mike wake up go to the coffee
shop and write um I think that when I
don't have a routine I'm a mess and I'm
not productive and it's not it's not
helpful so that so that's what I'd say
it's it's inconsistent the other thing
is I travel I mean what would the think
of her jokes show I toured a hundred
cities in a year and so it's it's very
hard to have rituals when you're going
to a hundred cities in a year yeah I
wonder if it makes the value of the
rituals even greater if you are able to
maintain some semblance of routine when
touring yeah I don't know I've never
done that do you have do you have a
favorite venue in the entire United
States if you had to pick one oh gosh
there's so many
I mean the upper Citizens Brigade
Theatre in New York City it feels like
home because I've been on that stage a
lot and the Comedy Cellar
in New York feels similarly I think that
in terms of like a pound-for-pound venue
I think the Chicago Theatre is probably
your best concert venue in America
Chicago theater seats about 3,000 people
and yet as a performer you feel like
you're talking to people in your living
room and as an audience member it feels
like you're just you know you're just
you're just watching you know someone
not in your living room but sort of you
know in it feels intimate see you are
you're a collector of good advice what
is the worst advice that you hear or see
being given out often and that could be
in any domain could be comedy could be
writing could be movies could be
completely unrelated anything it's all
about you know it's all about getting
your dream pursuing your dream like I
feel like there's something I I don't
know what the exact advice is that
drives me crazy but I think there's a
cultural thing right now that it is kind
of irks um which is that that people
feel like they're like I I read it
recently in the New York Times or some
said I'm forgetting her name who wrote
this but she said if I had advice for
college students it would be
don't ask what do I want to be when I
grow up ask how can I help or how can I
change the world or how can I make be of
service to other people and I think that
the that kind of like just kind of be
whatever you want to be is is perhaps to
be reconsidered by how can I be of
service when I'm on the earth for such a
short amount of time because when you
know when I do my shows like it's when
when I do my one-man shows for example
Seth parish and I we were always talking
about what how is this how is this story
that I'm telling you know about let's
say sleepwalk with me it's a story about
it's a story about how I jumped out a
second-story window while sleepwalking
it nearly killed me I was you know I got
cut up I ended up in an emergency room I
was that I had I jumped through a window
in the glass missed my femoral artery by
you know a centimeter and and and
ultimately we had to figure out not how
is this show how is this story about me
but how is it about the audience and the
way that we discovered it was about the
audience is that the that it's a you
know that it's about it's about the
catharsis you can experience by sharing
something that you're very embarrassed
about in my case having this
life-threatening sleep disorder that I
was embarrassed about I thought people
would think I'm crazy it's about the
catharsis of opening up and telling
people that and how that can make us
feel closer to one another and so in
that sense this is a roundabout way of
saying I'm always trying to think about
how does how can my how can what I'm
doing be helpful to the audience how can
they go away feeling empowered in their
life as opposed to oh that was funny you
know because because walking away going
oh that was funny it's I don't know it's
it's there's something about it that
feels like it's a missed opportunity
well I I remember speaking to John
Favreau on the podcast about writing and
his writing and humor and he said I
don't know I'm paraphrasing here but I
don't aim for funny I aim for truth and
then yeah funny you know often comes
along with it
I think that's absolutely sure there's a
there's a so on this point sort of what
you can offer of service so Brian
Koppelman mentioned something in our
text exchange which was he meaning you
chooses to be kind it's a conscious part
of who he he is and I'm always
interested in how he consistently thinks
of other people in whatever engagement
and how going through life that way
makes him feel can you confirm or deny
or elaborate on that because it's it's I
mean it's I think an observation worth
exploring mean is that if that is a
decision you make has it always been the
case is it something that you came to a
particular way I think I think that's
from my mother
um my mother is a very generous person
she's a she's a nurse for a whole career
and then she was a school nurse for a
while um Elementary School she's she's
very Catholic um which is not something
that I've followed in her footsteps with
but uh she's yes she's just very sweet
to everyone and I try to be I mean I
don't know if it's true it's nice to
hear that someone says that I about me
but I'm I I try I try to be nice to
everyone I mean I think it's it's the
right thing to do I think that you know
I think that piece you know on earth is
achieved in a micro sense I think it's
peace is achieved through every person
who you meet in your day is is that an
opportunity
contribute to peace everywhere right I
mean I mean maybe that's it's naive but
but I that's how I that's how I think of
it I don't think it's naive I mean I
think the the macro is made up of the
micro right and that I remember this
story I heard I believe it was from a
professor at Stanford named BJ Fogg who
decided to teach a class as professors
at Stanford it allowed to do that he
effectively made up out of thin air and
I think it was creating world peace or
something like that had no idea what the
syllabus or the curriculum would be
whatsoever and then 30 students show up
and he tries to figure out what the
class is and what he realized very
quickly is that you had students from
say Israel Palestine all over the place
no one could even agree on what World
Peace meant like what is world look like
they said okay since we can't agree on
world peace though and this was the
interesting part he said let us try to
agree on what the antecedents to world
peace would be smart what are the
constituent parts that might make up
world peace let's start to agree on some
of the ingredients and then he had them
work on projects focused on those common
ingredients so I got and I do feel like
to take something like peace and make it
actionable by necessity you're going to
bring it down to the micro otherwise
it's just not actionable it's too
abstract yeah I hope by the way I'm
fearing as I'm saying this like that
someone's listening to this going well I
met Mike Birbiglia and he's an [ __ ] I
have that with cue days like a lot of
times with touring with don't think
twice people that will do q and A's and
I'll be like 20 minutes into it and
it'll it'll hit me like a ton of bricks
like what if the people in the audience
didn't like the movie now they're
listening to someone babble on about how
they made the thing that they don't even
like well you imagine a worse fate than
listening to someone talk about a thing
that they you don't even like well I you
know I I have to say and this is not
gonna get a lot of sympathy for most
people listening to this but I have
a lot more empathy for people in the
public light than I did say ten years
ago because you see like II think you
wonder like I wonder if that guy thinks
I'm a total dick but it just so happens
like your cat got run over by a car and
like your kid pissed on your trousers
before we had to go to an important
meeting and then your wife called was
really upset and then some guy dropped
your coffee on the floor and you're just
in a shitty mood and that person happens
to come up to you like as you're running
to the gate to catch a flight that
you're gonna miss and yeah I have a 30
second exposure to you in a really rare
off moment and they're like wow that guy
is an [ __ ] and like were you
literally just or you literally just
rained your wrist like grabbing for a
suitcase I had that happen on this last
trip yeah yeah and it's just someone
someone comes up to you right at that
moment I was like hey I'm a big fan like
I'm this is a really strange thing to
say I'm in a lot of pain right now
like yeah I met that guy he made up the
most ridiculous story he blamed it on
his wrist
yeah and I mean it's it's I mean I had
this experience yesterday which was
hilarious and infuriating at the same
time this is yet another reason to stay
off of social media and I saw this guy
who's supposed to be call him a
journalist or of a sort of a media
producer who had been pinging me via
text message for a while I'd been
traveling out of the country this and
that to like get together have drinks
and like hey buddy how's it going all
this and I guess I didn't reply to them
and so his tweet was you know Tim
Ferriss is like an arrogant
self-centered ass but it doesn't mean
you can't learn lessons from him and I
was like oh so this is what happens when
I am out of the country for two months
and missed some texts like they assume
they assume malice so though I remember
as a piece of advice I was given or read
at some point I mix those up was you
know never never attribute and I've
modified it a bit but like never
attribute to malice what you can
attribute to incompetence now the way
I've modified that is never attribute to
malice what you can attribute to
incompetence or busyness oh yeah it's
like you don't know what battle someone
else is fighting like they might come
off as a dick and it's
like I'm not gonna give away too much in
the movie but it's like something
catastrophic could have happened that
they're not being open about because
they don't want to be open about it and
yeah you know just assume that it's not
a personal attack but I'm getting up on
a soapbox let me show myself out I I
think that's that's good advice uh what
is the best you've done you said a
hundred hundred cities right is there
yeah is do you have a favorite meal that
comes to mind and maybe it's pizza could
be but is there is there favorite meal
or drink of yours that comes to mind I
think that some some combination of like
I love great macaroni and cheese like I
like like I like I love going to like
the fanciest restaurant you can imagine
and just ordering macaroni and cheese or
like ordering the hamburger like like
big if you go to someplace that some you
know 50 bucks a plate or something like
that like sure you can order the chicken
or the steak or whatever but man can
they make a hamburger now are you
deliberately is that for your joy or is
it to like no i remote ly flog the
kitchen I think so you're not asking for
like super well done because I know that
makes chefs completely insane no no no I
think it's a cuisine loophole I think
that it's I think it's a great secret in
cuisine which is that you to order the
kind of inexpensive pedestrian item on a
really expensive fancy menu is more
often than not amazing like to go to a
tap to go to a fancy restaurant if you
like if you're in a fancy restaurant and
for whatever reason like there's peanut
butter and jelly on the menu order the
peanut butter and jelly because those
people aren't [ __ ] Oh God I love it
no that's good advice I remember I I had
two different pieces of advice from two
very good chefs so one said if you go
out to a restaurant never have the roast
chicken because you can always make
roast chicken at home smart like you can
always make it at home
but I had someone else say if you can
get roast chicken on the menu at a fancy
restaurant get the roast chicken cuz
everyone can make it at home you think
you know roast chicken oh yeah maybe
along the lines of the PB&J so if you
maybe it's order the PB&J if you could
have one billboard anywhere with
anything on it what would it say it
would say I put it like in Times Square
and it would say none of these companies
care about you like it because it's
because I think that that's that's one
of the things that I feel like I've
learned over the years which is like
that that we've we've come to trust
corporations in a certain sense and we
we forget the fact that they'd actually
have no vested interest in us other than
our money which is you know and which
harkens back to the thing I was saying
about gatekeepers which is like you know
people always say to me like hey I have
I haven't a very much of a niche career
I have a career where if people know my
work more often than not they're like oh
that's that's great yeah I'm a huge
friend this is great what you do and but
most people don't know who I am it's
it's the definition of niche you know
I don't get stopped in the street almost
ever which is great it's phenomenal and
so and so in relation to that is I do
things that are self produced you know
I'm a producer on my movies and my
producer or my one-man shows I produced
my tours it's all in-house and I try not
to to kind of bow to the gatekeepers of
show business because I they don't care
about me I mean they really don't like
they think that the network's in the
studio's all they care about is whether
or not my movie or my TV show or
whatever it would be would make them
money but so why would I try to why
would I try to please those people are
the people I'm trying to please is my
audience they're the people who who buy
my albums or buy you know who go buy
take buy movie tickets in SEMA those are
the people I care about those are people
I'm making movies for so I would say so
my billboard is the
these companies don't care about you do
you have any other rules that you've
developed for the I was going to say the
business side of the art that you're
involved with but just in terms of
managing your life and career there are
any other rules you've set for yourself
that have helped you to have the success
and longevity that you've had I think
it's I think my advice is just to try to
figure out what what this what they do
well in this kind of the system the
studio system the network system and
just pull it out and replicate the parts
that you think work and and then do the
rest yourself so so like in other words
I went my first off-broadway show was
sleepwalk with me and it was very much
like by the book and it was you know
like it was it was produced in this way
that you know it was the off-broadway
like system like it was you know it had
a you know a general manager general
management company that took
such-and-such a fee that had you know
this many people who are on the payroll
and all this kind of stuff and my aging
and I after the fact because the show
even though it was like this big success
and it ran for eight months this show
technically this is a very common thing
in Hollywood's like it lost money
technically like it wasn't like the flu
I guess the most famous story of this is
the Simpsons like The Simpsons
franchise I don't know if this is true
still but like for a few years ago it
was like it was not in profit have you
ever heard that story I haven't heard
the story of The Simpsons but I've read
some some articles on Hollywood
accounting and Hollywood accounting
right it's completely bonkers I mean
it's it's it's on par with like wait I'm
making this up I don't know if this is
accurate so don't sue me GM but when
people are like oh yeah GM paid no taxes
last year or like Apple I have no taxes
last year like what
it's it's absolutely on par like oh the
movie grossed a billion dollars but no
one saw any back end participation
mysteriously for these various reasons
that are detailed in this article but no
I haven't heard the Simpsons example but
yeah so so in so and so like you know
another my last movie sleepwalk with me
I won't sort of name the names that
involved but like it didn't it didn't
technically make money even though it
did like two and a quarter at the box
office was just a lot for a small film
that was made for a million dollars and
then it did you know probably a million
whatever maybe more digitally on Netflix
and iTunes and all these things and so
it may acquit him quote made like three
somewhere between three to five million
dollars we made it for a million dollars
budget which is like nothing in the
world of independent film yeah superb
engine and the movie didn't make money
and it doesn't I mean I'm trying to
curse it doesn't [ __ ] make sense it
doesn't make sense at all and so this
time around I was like alright well I'm
gonna cut out all the people who charged
the movie so to speak and happy became
like a line item in the budget for the
marketing and the distribution of the
movie and I'm just gonna do it myself so
like don't think twice is essentially
self distributed in cooperation with
this company the film arcade which is
like a small distribution company that I
basically told my story to and we're
like well let's build this from scratch
I'll go from town to town I'll go to 30
cities and I'll hand-deliver this movie
and so like this sum my whole summer has
been me going town to town showing sneak
previews of the movie and then doing a
free improv workshop for improv theaters
in that town so we're going to go in
Chicago and UCB in New York and the
torch Theatre in Phoenix and the you
know all of the planet ant theater in in
Detroit which is where keegan-michael
key started and we're doing these free
workshops just has like an act of
goodwill because basically we thought
like well why don't we instead of like
buying a ton
TV ads and this and that all the
traditional marketing why don't we spend
that money just just having me be a
walking billboard for the movie and go
town to town and spread goodwill say hey
we're gonna do free improv workshops
we're gonna do we're gonna give out free
tickets to local Improv theaters and and
we're gonna do Q&A and I saw any way
it's or to get back to what you're
saying in a business sense I would say
steal the ideas that corporations use
that work and then fill in the rest
yourself yeah
steal the Thunder from the gods she
doesn't actually belong to them anyway a
lot of senses I'm really excited about
that I'm continually excited about this
type of experiment and particularly
given my experience with the podcast
which after many many years is really
the first in a sense aside from the blog
and so on the first free agent
Enterprise that I've had complete
unilateral creative control over yeah
and it's the doctor is asian of podcast
has been incredible for radio oh it's so
it's just such a boon and such a joy and
for that reason I mean I'm going to be
experimenting with a lot of different
approaches with publishing as it relates
to books and otherwise because every
time I have in the past let someone pay
for something which is usually below
didn't yeah in some capacity as you
mentioned yep you publish the whole
publishing industry is bloated yeah you
you own your hey you will not have the
control of the protections that you
would want as a doer so how can people
see the film and of course it's kind of
contingent I suppose upon when people
are hearing this but what would you how
would you like people to check it out
and I I have really been enjoying it
Chris Sacca loved it I've heard great
things from a number of different people
and I certainly recommend people check
it out but where can they where can they
learn more and see more they can there's
there's a site called don't think don't
think twice movie comm add the Twitter
handle at don't think my Twitter
at four bigsby IRB IGS and you can see
that like good you know I'm traveling
around the country to like 30 cities
it's gonna with people's help don't
think twice we'll get into you know
three to five hundred you know theaters
across the country and and maybe more
and it's in it but it's entirely
contingent on the people listening to
this like we like and I would just I I
met Nantucket Film Festival right now
and there's great movies there's this
documentary called tickle that's
phenomenal there's this movie called
other people that Kris Kelly made
there's meant the captain fantastic
which I was telling you about there's a
norman lear documentary there's so many
great independent films and what i urge
people to do is go to the theaters go to
your local cinema and see small films
that you know read a few reviews and go
to the ones that you think might work
for you but it really does help for
there to be more of them like no one's
getting rich an independent film but if
but if the movie makes a few million
dollars i'll get to make another movie
and i'll put my heart and soul into it
and so that's that's what i would ask
and the just for people who are
wondering i mean I obviously I shouldn't
say obviously but I'll say those people
have been listening to me or following
me long and if notice that I take
endorsing things very very seriously I
don't it's very easy to destroy
reputation that takes a long time to
build and I feel very comfortable
recommending this movie it's when I was
watching it earlier with Cal at one
point a few minutes into it he said wait
a second is this documentary or script
and I I mean that is just about the
highest compliment as it relates to
acting that appears completely natural
and I thought to myself wow like that is
a very rare comment and this is coming
from someone who's had a lot of
immersion in the arts and entertainment
also that's oh yeah so everybody
definitely check it out and I will put
all of the links in the show notes as
usual at 4-hour workweek
forward-slash HOD cast one last question
actually two last questions
this one is what is the best or most
worthwhile investment you've ever made
that could be time money energy and just
as an example to buy a little bit of
time so Amelia Boone who's been on the
podcast though she's won the world's
toughest mutter three times and is the
most successful female obstacle course
racer in the world her answer was to me
paying her first $450 entrance fee which
was a stretch at the time for our
world's toughest mutter so it seemed
like a huge stretch but it completely
set her on pun intended this course in
her life and she's also a power attorney
at Apple and it's just a complete
machine but um what would you what would
you offer is your answer to that I would
say spend 15 bucks on a yoga class two
years ago I think that I if I hadn't
started I feel like my body would have
broken down completely and I'd be you
know in a sling like I feel in my life
do yoga
after years of telling me that I should
do yoga which is you know it's hilarious
if you people don't have the visual
picture of me but like the or they might
but you know you wouldn't think of me as
someone who does yoga and I certainly
don't do it well but but it is if you
can find a good place for beginners oh
my god it's I find it to be completely
hell it's very helpful for being
productive and being healthy and you are
I think people are as old as their
joints feel so if you sit down a lot
it is good to stretch and I've been
doing a lot of AcroYoga for the last two
years and I've my hips and back have
never felt better
that's very the so it encouraged people
to also if for whatever reason you can't
manage to get tickets to stand-up comedy
by mr. burr Biggs if you see him in line
for a yoga class and want to get some
indirect comedy by watching yes
yeah downward dog and Cobra poses then
that is that is much like the culinary
loophole Euler I'll tell you this is
gonna sound like I'm kissing up but my
wife urged me to wedge this in somehow
which is the if they people just listen
the podcast and they don't have your
book get your work before our work week
I believe your first book respect just
how I was introduced to it
your work is um because I I have a
completely different outlook on vacation
now
the way that you talk about how the like
essentially we're working these eight 80
hour weeks let's say for this pie in the
sky idea of retirement at the end of our
lives that God knows what the hell that
even is anyway and and live that live
that retirement in fits and spurts in
the middle of your life so you
understand the perspective of what that
even is and because of that my wife and
I took a vacation to Laguna Beach where
I shut off my computer for five days at
the beginning of June it's literally
because of your book well thank you for
sharing that that makes that makes my
makes my day and Laguna Beach is a great
choice that's a beautiful yeah I'm an
amateur travel agent yeah the those
people haven't read the book yeah the
the balloon payment at the end for the
deferred life plan is far from
guaranteed guaranteed far from
guaranteed so it's it's good to good to
break up the work with many retirements
for sure is there any ask or request as
we wrap up any penny parting comments or
asks or requests from my audience
no just that you know file you know
follow the movie on don't think I don't
think movie on Twitter or follow me
adverb eggs on Twitter and and so and if
you you know like trust me that the
movies really good and I I think you'll
laugh and I think you might cry which is
which for you
no take someone on a date take a few of
your friends and yeah it's it's a
there's a lot of love that went into
making something that a lot of people so
far have liked and so yeah it would just
mean a lot to me
yeah else and it also supports an
ecosystem of creators creating with a
shop which I I'm extremely passionate
about and I think pretty well informed
regarding and I would just tell people
you know every time I have to or choose
to review something whether it's a book
or a movie or anything else right before
an interview I'm always nervous and I'm
just like oh god like am I gonna have to
tap-dance around the fact that I didn't
like something by the the glaring
omission of mentioning it or anything
like that and within five minutes of
putting this on I was like ah thank
[ __ ] god okay I don't have to deal
with any of that it was such a wash of
relief so I I do encourage people to
check it out and Mike I know you got a
lot going on right now you are you're
juggling yeah the all of the activities
that go with taking matters into your
own hands with endeavour like this and
so I certainly send good vibes to you
for the endurance the endurance and
courage and strength that you will need
on the road and this is great fun so I
really appreciate you taking the time
thanks and as a disclaimer to anybody
who's listening to this and going like
but I don't even like Mike Birbiglia is
comedy why am i listening to him talk
about it just know on a lot of days I
don't like it either
I'm just trying my best like anybody
else so we can ask man everybody's just
trying to get by one day at a time Mike
will best best of luck with everything
and to everyone listening as always I'll
mention it again you can find links to
everything including the movie including
social including books and DVDs and so
on that came up in the show notes as
well as those notes for every other
episode at 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash
Podcast and until next time and as
always thank you for listening hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis
but normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge 0.25
percent per year on assets above the
first 15,000 which is managed for free
if you use my link wealthfront comm /e
tim that is less than five dollars a
month to invest a thirty thousand dollar
account for instance now normally when I
have a sponsor on this show it's because
I use them and recommend them in this
case it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront com forward
slash Tim it's fast it's free there's no
downside that I can think of this
episode is brought to you by four sig
Matic I reached out to these Finnish
entrepreneurs after a very talented
Acrobat introduced me to one of their
products which blew my mind and the best
way possible
it is mushroom coffee what on earth is
this well it includes chaga mushroom
very powerful antioxidant considered a
superfood I was introduced to chaga by
Laird Hamilton the king of big wave
surfing of all things and it includes
another mushroom that is considered a no
tropic a smart drug and this is lion's
mane in the entire package just add it
to hot water tastes like coffee
there is only 40 milligrams of
caffeine's so less than half what you
would find in a cup of coffee so you I
do not get any jitters I do not get any
acid reflux or any type of stomach burn
and it put me on fire for an entire day
and I only had half of the packet so
this stuff is really amazing people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement right now this is
the answer so it is legal it will not
give you visuals that's something else
and you can try it right now by going to
4 Sigma techcom forward slash Tim that
is 4 sig Matic SI g ma t IC 4 SiC Matic
dot compound slash Tim and use the code
Tim to get 20% off your first order if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed for sig
Metacom forward slash